I found my new favorite tick tocker oh
yeah and I wanted to review him with you
yeah I just want to say how important it
is to go to the gym there's so many
benefits and it's made this feels like
NPC dialogue that whole vibe yeah I
don't give a if you haven't been to
the gym one day in your life today's new
day to start fresh and start reaching
your goals so
all right sorry what just joking about
in Grand Theft Auto and he just
walk by someone in the street and
they're like you should go to the gym
today
I just want to say you should go to the
gym every day rocket launcher
I don't give a what do you think
cars straight into him the gym has made
such a positive impact on me oh